What is up everybody, my name is Heath Adams and
I welcome you to this course called Linux for
ethical hackers. So in this course, we're going to
be covering a lot of things, we're really going to
be going in hammering down on the terminal and
the command line. And if you've never learned
Linux before, this is a really great start for
you, especially if you're interested in becoming
Ethical Hacker or a penetration tester. So enough
of my face. Let's go ahead and just dive right in.
Alright, everyone, welcome to this course titled
Linux for ethical hackers. Before we get started,
I'd like to do a little Who am I so my name is
Heath Adams. I also go by the cyber mentor. I am
a husband, first a hacker, a military veteran,
gamer sports fan and animal Dad, I am a former
accountant turned security geek. So I've been in
cybersecurity about three years now. And before
that, I was an accountant, I hated it pick that
that field for all the wrong reasons. So once I
went into it, and cybersecurity, I never looked
back. And I've never been happier. On the day to
day, I am a senior security engineer. I'm also a
business owner at TCM security. So before that I
was a senior penetration tester doing penetration
testing and ethical hacking, I branched out
and started my own business focusing on ethical
hacking, training and student development. So now
I'm doing that full time, along with a job as a
senior security engineer. Okay, so let's go ahead
and talk about what we'll learn in this course. So
this course is going to be all hands on. Besides
this little introduction here, you're not going
to see a lot of PowerPoint besides quick overview
of what the course or the video that you're
about to see has coming. So 95% hands on course,
I will not kill you with PowerPoint. That's not
my goal. We're going to be focusing on Kali Linux
this entire course, and really learning Linux
and learning Linux for the purpose of becoming
ethical hackers. So we're going to install VMware,
which is a virtualized software, virtualization
software, and then we're going to run Kali Linux
inside of VMware. After that, I'm going to give
you a overview of Kali Linux, show you some of the
common tools, what it can do, why it's awesome.
And then we're going to do a deep dive into the
terminal. So what that means is we're going to
be hands on doing commands and learning Linux.
So we'll be running, navigating the file system.
So how to get around in the file system from the
terminal, we'll learn about users and privileges,
how to add users how to what kind of privileges
and permissions are there what important files
exist regarding those, we're going to talk about
common network commands. So if you want to be a
pen, tester, or ethical hacker, you need to know
networking, at least at a basic minimum. So we'll
talk about those common network commands that you
should know how to run them what they do, we'll
talk about viewing, creating and editing files.
That's obviously important if you want to create
a quick file or edit a file from the command line,
how you can do that. We'll talk about starting and
stopping services such as a web server, SSH,
SQL database, etc. We're going to talk about
how to install updates, how to install tools
and how to update those tools. And then lastly,
we're going to put everything we learned together
and do some scripting in bash. So we're going to
write a basic bash script, and then we'll improve
upon it and then I'll show you some four loops,
some other logical scripting ideas, and then
we'll kind of put that together and hopefully,
come to a nice completion when it's all said and
done. So with all this being said, I'm excited
to have you in the course with me, I look forward
to teaching you and let's go ahead and start with
installing VMware. Alright, the first thing that
we're going to need to do is to install software
called VMware Workstation player. Now we have two
ways to run Kali Linux, we can either run Kali
Linux through a virtual machine, or we can install
it as an operating system on a hard drive for this
course, and this lesson, we're going to be using a
virtual machine. and preferably, we're going to be
using VMware Workstation player. I'm going to show
you how to install VMware Workstation player and
I'll show you some of the alternatives to it as
well. So let's go ahead and dive right in. Okay,
so if you go out to the interweb, and you go to
Google, and you type in VMware Workstation player,
the first thing that will come up for you is
this download VMware Workstation player link.
You're going to go ahead and just click on this
and now I also want to introduce alternatives. So
there is a another software platform called Oracle
VirtualBox. And you will be able to install either
my preference in the course that's going to be
taught the rest of the way through is going to be
in VMware Workstation Pro. But we will use player
for the install, you'll be able to follow along
with player you will also be able to follow along
with Oracle VirtualBox if you so choose. But we
will not be showing that installation. Another
thing that should be noted is there is this
comparison page here and I will be using VMware
Workstation Pro. There's a nice little checklist
here that shows what pro can do versus player, he
has a lot of the same features here. Some of the
nice things is running multiple VMs at once. You
can technically do that with VMware Workstation
player, there's workarounds for it. But to have
it in a single tabbed interface. It's very,
very nice. You see here, the drag will tabbed
interface. That's another feature snapshots.
So basically making a backup of your machine all
included in workstation Pro. So if you have some
money to shell out, and this is something
that you're interested in doing long term,
it may be worth looking into a workstation pro
license, but by all means you can get away with
a workstation player installation, and that's
exactly what we're going to do. So let's go back
to the first tab here. And you can see it says
try VMware Workstation player, we're just going
to scroll down and this install and everything
is going to be running on top of windows for
me. If you're installing for Linux, that's fine
as well just follow your instructions for your
respective OS. Go ahead and select Download now.
I'm going to save the file. Okay, it downloaded
I'm going to hit run. It's going to ask if we want
to accept the changes, yes. Okay, now we're going
to hit Next we'll accept the license agreement and
possibly give away our firstborn. I'm going to go
ahead and check yes, for the enhanced keyboard
driver. We don't need to check for product update,
we don't need to join the VMware customer
experience improvement. We'll hit Next on that,
you can leave both of these checked or check
to your preference. And then hit install. And
while this is installing, I can actually show you
what VMware pro looks like. This is a pro instance
running here you can see they have the tabs and
they're draggable as it was notated in that,
that differential spreadsheet that you saw, and
I've got a Cali instance running, that's actually
my main Cali machine. I've got windows 10 running
here. And this is all actually sitting on top of
a real windows 10 machine as well. So we're just
installing workstation player, I'm going to run a
VM inside of a VM. So this can be a little bit of
Vm ception here, and then we're just going to hit
finish. And then we are going to restart this
machine as it needs a reboot real quick. Okay,
now we are restarted and we're back to our desktop
here, you can see that VMware Workstation player
has been added to the desktop. Let's just go ahead
and double click that to open it. And we're going
to choose to use VMware Workstation 15 player for
free for non commercial use. If we wanted the pro
edition, we would enter in our access key here
license key and continue on with the pro edition.
And now we will use the Finish button
here and we will be brought to our VMware
Workstation 15 player. So you can see here
that it's a much different view, it's very,
very basic. We have the option to open a VM here
and we'll have the one VM stored in this tab that
we can open up and that'll be it. There are ways
around running multiple VMs at the same time,
but if you're looking to build a fluid lab out and
have multiple VMs running similar to what I have
here, having the VMware pro again, it does have
its benefits here. So you can see this is a much
much different look. This is very generic as we we
can see here. So from here, what we're going to do
is we're going to go ahead and stop in the next
video, we are going to focus on downloading Kali
Linux and we'll talk about what Kali Linux is
and some of its features as well. So I'll catch
you over in the next video. Alright, now let's
move on to installing Kali Linux in our VMware
software. Okay, so picking up where we left off we
had just installed VMware Workstation 15 player,
and now we need a VM to actually be able to play
with it. So this whole course is going to be based
on Kali Linux. If we open up a internet browser
here, I've got a few tabs already opened. So what
I want you to do is go ahead and go out to Google,
and just type in Cali k L, I Linux download,
and leave it here. What we're going to do as well
is I want to talk just a quick second about what
Kali Linux is. So Kali, Linux is a Debian based
Linux OS. So it's based on pen testing tools,
and it's made for pen testers. So what it
does is it comes preloaded with a bunch of
penetration testing tools, a toolkit, if you will
call it and it is just made for people who are
looking to do pen testing. So this is provided
by offensive security. If you come to cali.org.
And you look at the About Us, it provides a little
bit of information about who the core developers
were and some of the moderators. But basically,
what it is, is it followed up a tool called or
distribution called backtrack. So the new the new
tool is Kali Linux. Now there are alternatives out
there. One of the alternatives right now is called
parrot. So if you go to parrot sec.org, and you
look into what is parrot, you can see that they
have different distributions. And they talk about
why parrots different, but they do have a pen test
distribution here. So for this course, we're going
to be using Kali Linux, but I always do like to
introduce the alternatives. Kali Linux is probably
more popular at this point, parrot OS is kind of
on the newer side, some people are starting to
get behind it and liking it, but I would say Kali
still dominates. The third option is that you set
up your own distribution. So you have an OS that
you like, and then you install the tools on the
OS that you like, and you have your own custom
build. So some people feel like, you know, Kali,
or even parrot, they come with a bunch of tools
that they'll never need. So their systems bloated,
and they really just have a set amount of tools
that they like, and if there's a tool that they
want to add into the system, then they'll download
that on their own. They don't want to have a ton
of bloatware coming with their system. But with my
experience in the industry, mostly everybody that
I've worked with is using Kali Linux, some people
are doing their own builds, especially on like the
webapp pen testing side. And then now parrot is
kind of that up and coming Oh s that some people
are transitioning to, but it is predominantly Kali
Linux. So that is why we're doing this course in
Kali Linux. And I feel like it's the best option
for us to learn some, just some basic Linux
skills and learning in the OS that is the most
dominant in the industry right now. So let's go
ahead and go back to that Kali Linux download.
In while this link has been clicked on, do not
let it fool you. We're actually not clicking
on the official Kali Linux downloads page,
we're going to scroll down a little bit, I want
to go to the Kali Linux custom image downloads
page and I'll show you why here. So this is that
offensive dash security Comm. Make sure that's the
one you're following along with. And if you scroll
down just a bit, you see that they're providing us
VMware images and VirtualBox images. So remember,
when I told you that VirtualBox was an option,
if you chose that option, here you go right here,
you'll click on this tab and you will download the
VirtualBox image. Now what we're going to be
doing is we're going to be running Kali Linux,
VMware 64 bit and we're going to download this
seven zip right here. You also have the option
to download a torrent if you'd like the file
size is going to be 2.4 gigs. So it might take
you a minute depending on your your speed of your
internet. And they also provide a Sha 256 some if
you want to check the file when you download it.
So I'm going to go ahead and just hit download
on this. And I'm going to save it and I will come
back as soon as this file is finished downloading.
Okay, so my file has finished downloading, I'm
going to navigate to the folder where it has
downloaded to which is the Downloads folder.
And you can see here that is a seven zip file.
So my installation by default does not have seven
zip. If you do not have seven zip either. We can
go ahead and download that together. So if you go
out to Google and you just type in seven zip, the
first thing that comes up is seven dashes zip.org.
You'll see a download tab here just go ahead and
click on that link and go ahead and download the
executable for your respective operating system.
So for me, I'm going to be downloading the 64 bit
Windows version here. And I'm going to hit save,
I'm going to hit Run, say yes, I'm going to go
ahead and install to the default directory. Okay,
now that's installed, let's go back to our folder.
And let's select that we open with seven zip here.
Okay, now let's see if we can drag and drop, we
can, so all I'm doing is dragging and dropping,
I'm putting it in the Downloads folder, you don't
have to do that you can drag it and put it in a
location that you would prefer, this is going to
extract I believe at a larger file size than just
the 2.5 gigs that we downloaded the 2.4 gigs. So
make sure that you have file space where you're
going to put this. So I'm gonna go ahead and let
this finish and then I will be right back. Okay,
so I've successfully unzip this file. And
just for the record, if we hover over it,
you can see that it actually extracted to be
10.4 gigabytes. So let's make sure that wherever
you extract it to you have the 10.4 gigabytes in
order to successfully complete the extraction. So
from here, let's go ahead and open up our VMware
Player. And we're going to go to player up in the
left hand corner, we're going to select file, and
then we're going to select open. And then we're
going to go to downloads. And we're going to go
into our Kali Linux folder here, and or wherever
you put it, if you didn't put it in the Downloads
folder, and then just select the one item that
should be here. It's a little four kilobyte file.
And what this does for us is it automatically has
a build, that's just ready to go. So this is
really awesome. We don't have to download the
image itself, and then install it and then pick
all the features. No, this just ready to go for
us. So we can also come down here and select
Edit virtual machine settings. And there are a
couple features here. So depending on the amount
of memory that you have on your machine, so right
now this is sitting at two gigs of RAM, that's
fine. If you want it to run faster, I recommend
going somewhere between four and eight. Obviously,
the more RAM you give it the the better it's
going to perform. But if you're running on eight
gigs of RAM for your machine, really not going to
do well for you. My recommendation is no more than
a fourth. So if you're running on 16, then maybe
give this four, you could really try pushing it
up to eight. But I am running on 32 right now.
So I could crank this up to eight by my rule here.
But just for working with you and following along,
I'm going to set this to two and then we're going
to perform into that way that we are working at
the same speeds across the board. Another thing
that we need to know is the network adapter, by
default, it's set to net, we're going to go ahead
and just leave that Nat here, Yours may come set
to bridge if for some reason it's set to bridge,
you can try that. But my default preference is
Nat. So let's go ahead and just hit OK. Okay, and
now we're just going to hit play virtual machine.
And a little side note, I am actually now on my
OS, I'm running on my, my Windows OS as opposed
to just running inside the VM. If I was running
a VM inside of the VM, I'd have a lot of issues,
segregation, etc. So now I've actually moved
out of the VM and have this running and player
on my Windows OS. Okay, and then when we get this
pop up here, go ahead and just say I copied it.
And this will start the machine. And you
can see the other VMware Player back here,
it's going to go ahead and directly just start
loading up here and we get to this screen. So
we click in and if we try to just enter in our
username and password, our username by default
is going to be root. Our password is going to be
root backwards, so t o r and then hit enter. Now
we can make this full screen over here by clicking
this button. It will enter into full screen mode.
We are now successfully logged into our Kali Linux
machine. We've installed this successfully and now
we are ready to start learning. So that's it
for this video in the next video we're going
to be doing is we're going to cover some of the
tools and features of Kali Linux. And we'll start
talking about what it's capable of and then we'll
dive right into the terminal after that and start
learning some. So command line and some useful
tools with Linux. So I will catch you guys in
the next video. All right, now let's take a look
around Kali Linux, and just see what it has to
offer us in terms of tools, design, etc. So let's
dive right in. Okay, so we're at our desktop here
inside of Kali Linux. Now you see the Kali Linux
logo, you see, there's a couple of things on the
desktop, you don't have to worry about these.
These are just from VMware themselves put on
your desktop. If you install this as an actual
OS, this will not be here. So when we talk about
navigating around Kali Linux, there's a couple
places that we can look, if we look right away,
you can see on the left hand side over here, we've
got a favorites bar. So we've got our folders.
So if we click on the folders or files, we can
navigate around this feels like any other machine,
right? We have our documents, downloads, music,
pictures, if you're a Windows user, or Mac user,
whatever this feels pretty common. So this is a
GUI or graphical user interface way of interacting
with the folders. As you move on, and we move
on in this course, we're going to be living
in the terminal. So the terminal is right here.
If you click on the terminal, this is something
similar to your command line. So from here, we can
actually navigate to all these folders here. And
we can put files in there take files out anything
that we can do in a graphic point of view,
we can also do from this command line point of
view as well. So as we learn, we're going to get
a little less relying on the graphical interface.
And more on the terminal side of things, however,
do know that there are ways to do a lot of things
from a graphical side, if you still need that,
that interaction with the machine and you don't
want to be completely keyboard oriented. There
are also tools on the side over here, if we look,
we've got a leaf pad. So leaf pad is just like a
notepad, right, or, you know, just your notebook
here, you can take some quick notes, save it out,
should be pretty familiar for you as well.
So they've got Firefox, it used to be called
iceweasel. And that's just your web browser. Down
here are some of the tools that you may use. Now,
burp suite is a very popular tool for web
application penetration testing, we're not gonna
be getting into any of these tools at the moment.
But I will cover what a couple of them do. So
again, burp suites, a web application penetration
testing tool, if you ever get into web app,
or if you even get into some basic pentesting,
chances are you're going to start using burp
suite on a pretty regular basis. Over here is Zen
map. Now this is the graphical version of a tool
called n map. And you will be using n map pretty
religiously when you're doing pentesting. So if
you like a visual view of doing scanning, so n
map is a network mapper, it allows you to scan
machines for open ports, and for vulnerabilities.
So if you want that in a more of a visual type of
view, or graphical interface type view, then you
have Zen map as a feature. This little guy down
here is meta sploit. Now meta sploit is a tool
that can be taught all these are tools that can
be taught in deep, deep lessons all by themselves,
not to make that intimidating for you at all. Just
know that that's how robust This is we're looking
at three tools right here, and they're all very,
very powerful. And this isn't even the half
of it or the quarter of what Kali Linux has
to offer. So meta splay, you may have heard of
it. If you've heard of anything in pen testing,
it is a framework that does just a little bit of
everything. So a lot of pen testers live and die
by this. It's a fantastic tool in my opinion. And
you're going to get very, very intimate with it
very, very quick if you do move into pentesting.
Down here is a tool called cherry tree and that's
pretty much where I'm going to stop we've
got multigo in Kismet, these are just this is
wireless base and this one here is is information
gathering base, but cherry trees Another useful
one. If we open that up. This is actually another
note keeping tool like I showed you leaf pad leaf
pads just for quick little one offs. cherry tree
is more of note keeping as a whole. So you've got
nodes that you can add so you can add a node
here and just say say you're following along
and you want to add notes. You can say Linux you
know and then you have a note You can add all of
your notes in here. And then you can actually add
children nodes as well. So maybe there's a command
that you want to add in. So say, we're covering
commands and you want to write all the commands
in about Linux down here, you could do that as
well. And then save this out. Nice thing too,
is that you can take screenshots and put them
in here. And exports really nice. And this is
going to be very, very useful for anything in
your career. But when it comes to pen testing,
there are so many tools, so many commands that
I think it is incredibly important to be able to
take notes and cherry tree is built in already.
Personally, I use what used to be in Kali Linux,
which is a tool called keep note, but cherry tree
is a great alternative as well. So either of them
would work in i is highly recommended by me that
you use some sort of note keeping tool as you
go through your courses and get better as a pen
tester. So I'm going to close out of this here.
And I want to show you a couple more things, you
have a feature here where you can show all of your
applications. So if you click on that, it'll bring
up all the applications, including the ones that
are grouped down here. Another way to do this
is if we come up into applications at the top,
you can see that everything is grouped really
nice for you. So it goes through the steps of
penetration testing. And let's say that like,
a, I'm gathering information on a client, okay,
well, here are some of the built in tools for
information gathering right here. Say you want
to do a wireless assessment, and you want to
do that those sorts of attacks, you've got all
these wireless tools built in for you right here.
Now chances are, you're going to be running these
tools from the command line. So again, you know,
you don't want to get too hung up on the graphical
side of things, as you may not always have access
to that either. But it's important to know what
tools that you have in front of you. And there
are even tools like Wireshark in here. So very,
very useful, pretty much a little bit of
everything that you can imagine. So just,
you know, take some time and go through the
tools. And if you're becoming a pen tester,
you're working on it, you know, just just, you
know, look at a tool and do some research on it.
Say you want to know what this MAC changer is.
It might be obvious, it might not be obvious,
right? So maybe you go Google, what Mac changer
does, how to use it, what the syntax is, and then
you play around with that, pick a new tool every
day, figure out something that you can do with it,
how to use it what it does. But so Kali Linux
is a distribution full of useful tools. And
it it you know, for a base OS, it's fantastic.
And this is why so many people in the industry,
just download this, install it and they're
ready to go. You know, we talked about in a
previous video, how there are other OSS or there
are people out there that like to just do their,
their base install. And you can see that there's
bloatware here, if you want to call it that,
right. Like there's forensic tools. And maybe
you'll never do any forensics in your life.
And you don't need all this installed in your
system. So if you're a type of person that is,
you know, it doesn't want this extra stuff,
there's extra software on your system, okay,
then maybe you do start moving towards that custom
build. Eventually, in your career, you say, hey,
I want I want to learn all these things first.
And then once I learned what tools I really like,
then maybe you move to your own distribution that
you create yourself. And you spin that up every
time instead of having all these tools built in.
But as a basis as something that you can learn
from and start with. This is why I've chosen Cali
and this is why we're going to learn it today. So
let's go ahead. From here, what we're going to do
is we're going to dive right into the terminal.
So let's just open this terminal. And then we're
going to fullscreen it and move on to next video.
So from here on out, what we're going to be doing
is we're going to be living in this terminal.
I'm going to back away from the graphical side of
things and really just get your your hands dirty,
in the terminal make you feel comfortable. If
you've never used Linux before, this is perfect
for you. So I'm going to give you the the pen
tester perspective on why we're doing a lot of
these things. Some of these commands are going to
be the same commands, regardless if it's on a Kali
Linux machine or if it's on another distribution
of Linux. So you'll be able to take a lot of these
commands and just use Linux and another system
as well. So if you're interested in pentesting,
if you're interested in Linux, this is where we
really get into the meat of the course and it
should get interesting for you. So I will catch
you over the next video we're going to start
talking about how to navigate File System and get
comfortable with that. Alright, on to navigating
the file system. So first let's talk about some
of the commands we're going to learn today. So
we're going to learn about pwd, which is present
working directory, we're gonna learn about CD,
which is how we change directories. We're going
to learn about LS, which is going to be listing
the files in a folder or in a directory. And we're
also going to talk about how to find some hidden
folders with LS. We'll talk about how to make
a directory and to remove a directory, we're
going to talk about copying, removing moving and
locating files. We'll talk about something called
update DB and how that pertains to locating files.
We'll talk about the password and how to change
our password. And we'll talk about an important
command called man. So by the end of this first
lesson, you should be pretty comfortable with all
of these commands and may seem a little daunting,
but they all kind of play in with each other.
Again, please make sure to take notes you got
cherry tree built in. You can also use keep
note or even just a notepad in front of you,
that'll help with the experience. And also maybe
watching the video more than once will help with
the experience as well. So let's go ahead and
dive right into the command line. So now our
first lesson in Linux terminology is going to
be navigating the file system. So if you're a
Windows user, you're used to navigating your file
system probably through folders through a GUI, so
a graphical user interface. Well, in Linux, we can
do that. But the majority of time we're going to
live in this terminal here. So we really need to
know how to get around. So the first thing we can
do here is we can say Hey, where are we at? And
that's a pwd. So that stands for present working
directory. So you type that in, you hit Enter.
And it says, Okay, we're in the root folder. So we
know that we're in the root folder, but how do we
get out of the root folder, we can use a command
called CD. And that stands for change directory.
So if we want to change directory backwards,
we just type in two dots here. And now we can
say, okay, where are we at? So we're in a slash.
So we're just in a home folder here are just there
our generic slash folder, right? So what we can do
is, well, how do we know Can we go backwards? from
here? Let's keep trying. So we do pwd. Again, no,
we can. This is our base folder, right? So you
have to think of this as the lowest you can go.
So now how do we move around? How do we know how
to go forwards again? Well, we don't know what's
in our directories, right? So we're sitting
in this the slash folder, and how do we look
around? So there's a command called ls that lists
everything that's in the folder. So if we say LS,
we kind of see this color coordinated here. And
the color coordination just depends on if it's
a folder if the folders read, right, you know,
there's permission settings, which we're going
to get into later. But the majority of these here
are folders. Okay, well, we know we just came out
of root so we can go back into root. Now, how do
we do that? So we can say, change directory root.
And we can actually hit tab to autocomplete. I
don't know if you caught that. But there's no are
any folder besides root. So at all, I can just
hit tab. And it should type it out for me. Oh,
I lied. There's a run in here somewhere, but it's
hidden. We're gonna cover that soon as well. So
our Oh, hit tab, autocomplete can change directory
into root. So let's LS and root and see what's in
here. Okay, this is more like our home folder,
right? So we've got desktop documents downloads,
this is kind of what applies to the root user. So
what if we're sitting in this root folder here and
we wanted to access instead this Etsy folder?
Well, could we do the same Etsy command here?
Well, I'm hitting tab, and nothing's happening.
Well, because Etsy doesn't belong in this area,
right. But if we put a forward slash in
front of it, because this is the base,
and then we hit et CIE, there, now we can navigate
to the Etsy folder, and we can actually double tab
and see what's all in the Etsy folder like an LS,
se no. Another way to do that is if we wanted to
LS what's in the Etsy folder without navigating
to it, we can just type ls Etsy, and you can
see everything that's in here. So there's some
some tricks that we can do right? So we don't
have to actually navigate to the folder to know
what's in there. Again, if we LS. And we want to
know what's sitting in videos, or even, let's
say what's sitting in desktop for our folder,
well, if we start typing desktop and hit tab, we
can't do that either. Because everything in Linux
is case sensitive. So if we start typing desktop,
and then hit tab, now, we can LS and see what's in
there. So our VM ware came with a couple of shell
scripts here that are automatically placed on our
desktop, we wanted to confirm that you could see
that they're both right here. So as of right now,
we are just sitting in our route home folder. And
we know how to navigate around. So if we wanted to
go to desktop, we could, we could hit LS now and
see what's in there. If we wanted to go backwards,
we could. Okay, now we're back in our, our root
folder. And you can also tell where you're at your
present working directory sits right here, right.
So this little a Tilda is actually your home
folder. And you can see that we're in desktop.
So if we wanted to go back into our desktop,
instead of typing, so you want it to go to music
from your desktop, instead of going route music,
which will work, you could also just say I
want to go music. And that'll put you there
as well. And notice you don't need the leading
forward slash when you use the automata. So
just some couple interesting tricks that
you will kind of pick up along the way,
tab is definitely going to be your best friend.
If you run into something with multiple options,
say you're trying to CD and you say I want to go
on my desktop and you're tabbing it's not working,
you can hit double tab, and then it'll show you
Okay, well, there's desktop documents, downloads,
those are your three options, start with a D. So
now you kind of have an idea as to how to kind
of move around. But let's do a little bit more.
So what if we want to make our own folder? Well,
there's something called make directory, MK
Dir. So if we say make directory, and we'll
say I'm just gonna use my name here. So now if we
LS, we can see that this he folder is now here,
we can go into the heat folder. And there should
be nothing in it right? So we can go back. And
we can also get rid of the heat folder, remove
directory heat, the LS again, it's gone. So now,
what else can we do? Well, we can also look
for hidden folders. So we can say LS dash LA.
And we can look for hidden files and folders here.
Remember the color coordination. So this dot cash,
right that in theory is a hidden folder. So if we
say CD dot cash, we can go into there we LS and
there's actually some some information in there.
But when you saw it originally, you didn't see
that, we're going to cover more on this, I just
kind of want to show you that trick. As you see
over on the left side, there's file permissions
and properties. So be aware that just because
it looks like something's not there, doesn't mean
it's not there, it might just actually be hidden
similar to Windows where you have hidden files and
folders. So just a quick trick to show you that.
So another thing we can do. So let's go back.
And don't worry about what I'm doing here, you're
going to cover these commands in a little bit. I'm
just going to echo Hi, and we're going to put that
in a test dot txt folder. So now if we LS, you
can see that test dot txt is here. So if we want
to actually copy this file, we can copy this file
to another location. So we can say, hey, I've got
this test dot txt, but I actually want to move
it to downloads. And if we go LS to downloads,
you can see that test dot txt is actually sitting
in there. And if we wanted to remove it, we can
just say remove from downloads, or test dot txt.
Actually, sorry, remove downloads test dot txt,
we don't have to transition into that directory
if we don't want to. So another trick, say we want
to see now that it's gone. We want to LS but we
don't want to keep typing this out. If you hit the
up arrow. Now you can just see your old commands.
So if you keep typing your command over and over,
you can see what's going on. So LS shows that
there's nothing in downloads now we were able
to successfully remove that file. So another
thing that we can do is we can actually move
so say we wanted to move test dot txt and we
wanted to put that In the downloads, okay,
now if we LS test dot txt is now gone from this
folder. Because we've moved it, we haven't made a
copy, we've actually physically moved it away.
So now if we LS Actually, let's just tab up,
you can see that test dot txt is now in
there. I'm going to remove that here. Okay,
and now the last thing I want to show you, is the
locate feature. So if we wanted to locate a file,
say I wanted to locate bash, let's see. So we're
looking for a file, and we're going to get more
specific along the way. But if you type
in locate, you can kind of look through a
system to see if you can find it. Now I'm looking
for, say, any type of bin bash or bin or bash,
that's fine. That's really what I wanted. But
it shows you everything with bash in it. Now,
this might not work right away, what you might
need to do is update the database. So you type
in update dB, it updates everything for you.
And then you can use locate again. So it has to
build that database of the information that it's
finding in order to locate what you're searching
for. So make sure that you use update DB sort of
frequently. Okay, so two more things I want to
show you. And then we'll close out this video and
move on to the next one. So an important thing you
want to do with your new account is we're using
a default password, and that's not very secure.
So to change a password for our user, we can just
type in pa SS WD. And now it's going to ask us for
a new password. So instead of using tour, we can
use something else. I'm going to type in the very
secure password as my password for an example
here. But if you plan on using this machine,
for future reference, you can type in a secure
password and kind of keep it. So lastly, I want
to show you is something called man. So man pages,
man pages are your instructions for any command
that you're running. Most commands come with a
man page. So let's say we want to look at LS, we
can say man LS. And then it's going to give us all
this information here about LS. So if you see it
says LS is list directory contents. Awesome. And
then it gives you what options we can do. Well,
we can do a dash a for all what you saw earlier.
And you can kind of scroll through here and just
see exactly what it has to offer. And that's
kind of it. So when you go through here, you
can kinda you know, if you're struggling to like,
you know, there's a command in there, but you're
not sure exactly what the command is, you can type
in man and search it. And sometimes you can do LS,
I don't know if this is going to work, but dash
dash help. And you get some information as well.
It doesn't provide you the full man pages, but
it provides you something pretty close. So that's
kind of just your way around if you ever get
stuck, something to look for. Okay, so that's it
for this lesson. Next, we're going to move on to
users and privileges, how to add users and how to
how to change some pseudos and some modifications
to our file permissions. So until next time,
my name is Heath Adams, and thank you for joining
me. Alright, now let's talk about users and their
privileges. So what are we going to learn in this
lesson, we'll do a quick user privilege overview.
From there, we're going to talk about the CH
mod command, which is the change mode command,
that's going to let us change the permissions on a
file or directory. We're also going to talk about
how we're going to add a user with the Add User
command. From there, we're going to take a look
at a couple of important files. One is the Etsy
password file. And the other is the Etsy shadow
file. So the Etsy password file is not actually
where the passwords are stored on a machine. That
is the Etsy shadow file which stores the hashes.
But the Etsy password file does store it where the
users what users are on the machine. And you can
correlate that to the shadow file. So we'll talk
about those in more detail and their importance
to pentesting. Very, very important. And then
we're going to talk about su which is the switch
user command. And finally, we'll talk about sudo,
which is a command that allows you to elevate your
privileges on a Linux machine. So let's go ahead
and dive right into our lesson. Okay, so now we're
going to cover users and privileges. So in the
last video, we touched a little bit on privileges
with our LS dash l A. And we touched a little bit
on users by changing the password of our root
account. So now we'll cover a few more commands
regarding those. So if we look at ls dash l A.
You could see all this crazy, jumbled wordage over
here, right? So it actually means something. So
we look at the first line here, if we see a dash,
like this a hyphen, that means it's a file. If we
see a D, that means it's actually a directory. And
then you see our W and x. So rW x actually means
read, write, execute. It's the permission settings
that this particular group has. Now there are
three groups here, there's the first, second,
and then your third right here, right? So your
first group, right here is the owner of the file.
So it looks like the owner of the file has full
READ WRITE execution, right. And then the next set
of three here is actually the permissions for
the members of the group that owned the file.
So this is a group ownership as opposed to actual
ownership here. So for the people that are in the
group that has access to this file, they can only
read and execute, they can't write to it. Now,
for the last one, this is just all their users.
So any common user here can actually just read
and execute, they can't write the document. So
that comes into play, especially when we get
into penetration testing, because with penetration
testing, we're looking to have full access, right,
so we're always gonna be looking for that folder
that has full READ WRITE. Typically, if we look at
temp, that's our temp folder. A lot of times, you
see the temp folder has full read, write, execute.
So when we're doing penetration testing, we're
trying to upload some sort of exploit, we might
actually upload it into the temp folder, because
that's where we can execute those, those files.
However, we could also be looking for other full
READ WRITE execute files, where we need to modify
them and give us root access to a system. So it's
all about insecure configurations. And we're going
to cover that more once we get into the actual
penetration testing part of the course. So for
the Linux essentials part of the course, all we
need to worry about is these file permissions.
Another important feature of that is if we were to
create a script, or scripts not gonna be able to
run until it has full access. So how do we change
access here. So let's make a file. I'm just going
to make all this echo another text document,
right, so we'll just say hello. And actually, I
typed that in backwards. So hello, and we'll call
it Hello dot txt. So if we LS here, by default,
we only have read write and then read access for
everybody else. Meaning if we wanted to read it,
we could say cat, which we're going to get into
later. Cat Hello, dot Tex, and it just says hello.
So what can we do here? Well, we can use something
called change mode, in changing mode is CH, Mo D.
And we have a couple options here. So we can do
a plus, right, and we could say, well, we want
READ WRITE, execute, or we just want execute. But
another way I like doing it is you have a number
feature. So the one you really need to know is
all sevens. sevens gives you full read write
access across the board. So if we say ch mod
777 Hello dot txt. Now we LS LA. And you notice
that Hello dot txt turns green, that means it
is full rewrite. And here you go. We've got
the dash here saying it's a file, and we've got
READ WRITE execute across the board. So this is
how we change file permissions. You don't need to
necessarily know about the other numbers in terms
of penetration testing, it becomes more in terms
of configuration and security management of files
if you were to get down that path. So just stay on
the easiest path. Just remember 777 or plus x will
work as well. So changing the mode is is critical.
And we're going to cover it time and time again
throughout the course, once we get a little bit
deeper. So a couple more things we need to talk
about. say we wanted to add a new user. Well,
there's a feature called Add User. So we say Add
User, and one or two names is allowed. So we need
to add user to john. Okay, so it made something
for john. Let's give him a password. Give them a
password again. And we'll just hit enter for the
default. It's all correct. Okay, so We now have
a user named john. And we can confirm that we can
actually cat The Etsy password file here. And you
see down at the very bottom, we have this user,
john. So this Etsy password file you're going
to become very familiar with, because it shows
you all the users now this will, there's a lot
of times when you're doing penetration testing,
you're gonna have access to this Etsy password
file, because it doesn't provide the password
anymore, it used to a long time ago, passwords
are now in the shadow file. So you actually have
a little bit of access and information disclosure
here at the hands of poor configuration. So you
see that I've created a user john, well, that
gives us a little bit of information, say there's
SSH on a machine or something else, we can use
that username for john to try to break into the
machine. So we'll cover that again later. But if
we wanted to see what the Etsy shadow file looks
like, now we come in here, and you've got these,
these jumbled stuff here, right? So it's just a
hashing format. So what we're doing is we can
actually use a tool like hash cat to break this
down and crack these passwords. Now, a password of
password will be very easy. But just know that if
you have access to the Etsy shadow file, you have
a good chance of cracking a password, depending on
your capabilities, and depending on the strength
of the password, that allow you access to a
machine. So something to think about there. Okay,
so now we have our user john, let's go ahead and
switch to him. So we can use something called Su,
which stands for switch user. And we'll say switch
user, john. Okay, so automatically gave us john
here, let's see if we could switch back to root.
Okay, we can't just switch back to root, because
we need roots password, right? So we can type
in password, and that works. But if we didn't
know the password, then we'd be stuck on john,
we are able to access john because we were already
root. So this comes into play in terms of users.
Let's go back to john here. Now, if your user
you have to be able to do certain things,
you need permission to do certain things I should
say, right, so root has full access and permission
to do everything. But john, we just created john
john doesn't have any sort of access. So if we
wanted to, if we wanted to change the password,
say we want to change the password for for root.
I can't modify the password information because
I don't have that kind of access. Now there is
something called a pseudo which would provide
john the access if we gave it to him. So it's
called a sudoers file. And basically, anybody in
that sudoers file can change permissions given
if they are a pseudo user, right? So we would
type in sudo, password root. And it's going to
ask for the password for john. But you're going
to notice, hey, John's not in the sudoers file,
john can't do this. So john has base permissions,
right. And we're going to counter that a lot of
times in penetration testing, where if we get in,
we'll get something called lower privilege. And
we'll get an account like john, and we're going to
try to escalate into root but we just can't do it,
you know, the chances of doing a doing that and
having a john in a sudoers file is just not high.
It's possible, but it's not likely. So for now,
just know that if you want a user other than root,
to have access to file permissions, you need
to have them in the sudoers file, that becomes
useful to in penetration testing, because you
can look at the sudoers file if you have access
to see what users have sudo privileges. Okay, so
that is it for this lesson. In the next lesson,
we're going to be covering network commands, and
moving on gradually towards scripting. So let's
go ahead and get there. And I will see when we
get over there. Alright, so now we're going to
be covering common network commands. So before
we dive into the commands we're going to learn,
I'm going to go on a tiny bit of a rant here.
So if you are not familiar with networking,
now's the time to become familiar with networking.
There are two things I think that a person needs
before they really can dive into pentesting. And
that is Linux experience, which you are gaining
some Linux experience now because most pen testing
is done in Linux. And the other thing is to have a
good network foundation. So if you're looking
at these commands here, and I say if config,
which if you're a Windows user, and you hear
IP config, do you know what that is? Okay,
that's basically the same thing. If you know what
ping is, if you know what ARP is netstat route,
those should all be pretty familiar where
you can guess what those are. If you do not
know what these commands are, you might want to
brush up on your networking as well. Because the
better you are at networking, the better you're
going to be when it comes to pentesting, because
you're going to have to navigate around networks,
you're gonna have to understand where you are at
in a network, you're going to need it for basic
troubleshooting as well. So just to understand
these commands are gonna be very important. But
what we're going to be doing here is we're going
to be taking common network commands that we're
going to be running as a pen tester. And we're
just going to apply those to their version in
Linux. Some of these may be familiar to you,
some may be new to you. But we're talking here if
config which is going to show us some information
very similar to IP config in Windows, where we'll
see our ipv4, ipv6 if we have it information,
our MAC address, things along those lines, our
subnet mask, etc. The IWC config is the wireless
adapter version of that. Ping is a ping command,
where we talk over ICMP, and we try to communicate
to another machine to see if it's alive and
responding back to us. We've got the ARP command,
which just maps IP addresses to MAC addresses.
And we've got netstat, which is just a command
line tool that's going to allow us to display all
connections and listening ports. And then finally,
we've got route which displays our routing
table. So we'll go ahead and take a little bit
of a deep dive into those in this next lesson. And
hopefully, this is a refresher for you. So again,
if not, then you should be looking into
some networking studies as well. Okay,
so let's go ahead and dive right in. Okay, so
now let's cover network commands. So the first
command I want to cover is if config. So you may
be familiar with the Windows version of this,
which is IP config. And they pretty much do the
same thing. So it shows you here, your different
interface types and the IP address associated
with them. So it's zero here, Ethernet zero,
has an IP address of 190 2.1 68.13 2.164, you can
see the netmask, the broadcast address, and you
can see the MAC address as well. And we also have
a loopback address here. Now, if your machine has
a wireless adapter, or at some point, you want
to do wireless penetration testing, you're going
to need a W config. And you should not expect
to see anything on this at the moment, unless
you're using a laptop, then you actually might see
configuration down here for it. If you would see
something under IWA config, you would see like a W
LAN one w land zero, something along those lines,
okay, and another common command that we're
going to see is going to be the ping command.
So we can just type in ping, and the address
that we're trying to talk to. So for example,
I'm going to try to ping my home router. And I get
talking back. So if I tried to ping something that
wasn't in my network, like a 16.1, you're gonna
see the results change. So with ping here, ping
is going to be endless, until we hit something
like Ctrl C to stop it, it'll ping forever. So
I'm gonna hit Ctrl C again, and kind of show you
the difference. So you see that we attempted to
ping here. And we got replies, we got information
back. Well, that's good. That means we're talking
to the other machine, it says, Hey, are you there?
It says, Yeah, I'm there. And we try to ping this
machine here. But this machine's not talking back,
it could mean that the machine is on the network,
or that the machine is just blocking ICMP traffic.
ICMP is a another word for Ping. So moving on to
the next command, I want to show you ARP. So the
best way I like to type in is ARP with a switch of
a and ARP is just going to show you MAC addresses
that it talks to and the IP address. Actually,
I said that backwards, it's going to show you
the IP address it talks to and the MAC address
associated with it. So if an IP address reaches
out, say 192168 15.1 talked out to this machine,
it's gonna say okay, Hey, who are you? It's gonna
send a broadcast message out to say who has this
IP address? And then the IP address will respond
and says, Hey, I do and this is my MAC address. So
ARP is just a way of associating IP addresses
with MAC addresses. And once you know that,
you can also look at netstat So netstat dash a and
O is another one of my favorite commands. And this
shows you just the active connections that are
running on your machine. So if we scroll way up,
and you can just kind of see what's open and
what's talking here, where this really comes in
handy on a penetration test is to see if a machine
is talking to somebody else. Same thing with ARP,
you want to know what that machine is associated
with? And is it talking to something on a port. So
this is more just internal right now, but it's
still good to know. So for example, if I were
to open up a Firefox page and connect out to the
internet, then I went and I did a netstat. Again,
I would see information about that port being
open and, and that I am going out with it. So
just kind of keep that in mind. These are not
commands that you really need to know in depth
right now. Networking does come into play when
you are doing penetration testing. But what we're
going to cover these commands time and time.
And again, I just wanted to give you a very
brief introduction to them. Okay, in the last
command that I have for you today is route C,
if you type in a route that's going to print
your routing table in the routing table is
important because it tells you where your traffic
exits essentially. So for this VM, my traffic is
exiting on 19216813 4.0. So any traffic goes out
of this 0.0 dot 0.0 gateway, in this range, right.
So when it goes out this gateway, it's doing Nat
so network address translation, and it's running
off my computer. So the best examples aren't here.
But it's important to know route as well, because
there could be a machine that you're attacking
that has multiple routes. So you might see a 134
and a 135. Because it has a dual home Nic meaning
it has two NICs inside of it. So it's actually
talking to a completely different network that
you didn't know existed. So you might have been
attacking one network on the 134 range, and then
135, just out there, and this computer can talk
to both and until that point, you had no idea. And
that's the idea of called pivoting when you switch
a network from one to the other, but you're using
a machine. So that's it for this lesson. In the
next lesson, we're going to talk about viewing,
creating and editing files. Okay, so viewing,
creating and editing files. This section sounds
exactly like what it is. We're going to talk about
how to view create and edit files. Mainly, we're
just going to be showing how to create quick text
documents. But we'll teach you commands that
will allow you to do further in the future,
as you will see as we get further in the course
and get into scripting. So let's go ahead and take
a look at some of the commands that we're going
to be learning. So some of the commands that we're
going to learn, we're going to learn the echo
command, which echoes what we write right back out
to the terminal, we're going to look at the cat
command, which is going to print out a document
for us it's similar to type in Windows, we'll
talk about replacing versus appending. And which,
which function does which and how to do it.
We're going to talk about the touch command,
which can be used to create a file on the fly.
We'll talk about nano, which is a text editor
that's built into the terminal. And then we're
going to talk about g edit, which is also a text
editor. But it is a GUI text editor. So we do get
a little bit of gooey in this lesson. So let's
go ahead and dive right in. Okay, so this is my
second time recording this video. The first time
I forgot to turn my microphone on and performed
for my cat. So she approved of it. Let's see if
you approve of it the second time around now that
I have a little bit of practice. So we're gonna be
talking today is really talking about viewing,
creating and editing files. So I've already
showed you the echo command. If you recall, we
used echo to create a file, right? We created
a Hello dot Tex. And we can just echo Hello
out to the terminal. We could say echo Hello,
and I'll say hello back. So what we can do with
echo is we can use it to write to a file. So if
we were to say echo, hey, and then we write it to
Hey dot txt. Well, we can look and see that hey,
dot txt is here. And you can see my files from the
previous one. So I'm trying to Come with more ways
of saying hello. But we're going to use hate text
here. So if we cat hate at tax, a all cat does is
print out to the screen what is in a file? It
says, Hey, okay, so let's say we want to append
cat are we want to append hate. txt? Well, we
can tab up here. What if we just say, hey, again,
we've got this greater than symbol here. And we're
just putting it into the hate. txt file. Well,
that didn't work. We didn't append it, we actually
overrode it. So what if what what can we use to
actually over append this, here's what we can do
is we could say, hey, again, again, right? Just
to give us something different. And we can add a
second greater than symbol here. So now if we cat
the file, you can see that we actually appended to
the end of it. So this becomes incredibly useful
when we are either adding stuff to a list say
we're gathering IP addresses, and we just want to
combine our lists, or when we're creating a series
of commands, and we're going to use those commands
to send all at once. We're going to cover that
later, when we're talking about file transfers
in the penetration testing section, where we use
a set of commands like this on a Windows machine.
To actually transfer files via FTP is just so
much easier than typing them all in one by one,
we can create a little document and run the
document. So this becomes useful when we have
a series of commands and for other reasons, as
well as you'll learn as you go on in your Linux
career. So we've talked about Echo, and we've
talked about cat. So let's talk about some other
ways to create a file, we can use something called
touch, and to say New File dot txt. And if we LS,
you can see that new file dot txt is here. But if
we cat new file, there's nothing in there because
they haven't put anything in there yet. So there's
a few things that we can do, we could use echo
and append the file, right? We can also use a tool
called nano. nano is a terminal text editor. There
are other terminal text editors like VI and vim. I
don't prefer those Personally, I like now the most
some people have their preferences. So I encourage
you to play around with any of them as you wish VI
and vim are the other two. But for this course,
we're going to be using nano. So if I say nano,
new file dot txt, I could type whatever I want in
here. We're going to be using nano a lot to create
scripts to create Python scripts. And to edit
shellcode as we get into a little bit exploit
development. So I'm going to hit Ctrl x, I'm going
to hit y for saving, and then we'll save it to new
file dot txt. If we cat this, now it says hey, I
could type whatever I want in here. So that's one
way of editing it. Another way of editing it is
using a graphical interface. So we can use g edit,
and say new file. And if you don't like using a
terminal, you're more than welcome to use g edit
here. Just type in new line here and save it. And
I like using g edit, it's a lot cleaner, because I
can you know, highlight and delete, I don't have
to use my keyboard to navigate around like I do
in the terminal. So if you have the option to use
g edit for sure, but sometimes you're going to be
on another machine that's not your own or is
headless and doesn't have a GUI that you're
going to have to use now. So get comfortable using
both. So we save this, let's go ahead and cat it
out and see what happens. Okay, you can see that
the new line is in there. So really, that's the
overview that I wanted to cover. So just know that
you can create files pretty much using echo touch.
And actually, you can create files using nano
as well. If you say nano, this is new text. I'll
just say hello, control x, save it, you LS you
can see this is new text is right here. So you
can use all of these tools in different ways to
create files, it's completely up to you how you
want to do it. Personally, when I'm creating a
file, I use nano and I just create a new shell
script Python script. txt document that way, you
could also do it using g edit as well. So just
know that we're going to be using these a lot and
try to get comfortable with these. And from here,
we're going to be moving into controlling callee
services. So we're just going to briefly talk
about what services you need running on boot and
how to do that. All right, In this video, we're
going to be talking about starting and stopping
Cali services. Let's go ahead and just take a
quick look at the commands we're going to learn.
So not a lot of commands in this video only two,
we're going to talk about the service command,
and the system CTL command. So the service command
deals with services, it's going to allow us to
start and stop services on the fly. And the system
CTL command is going to allow us to enable or
disable services so that they load up on boot, or
do not load up on boot. So let's talk a little bit
more about services and look at how these commands
can be useful for pentesting. Alright, so let's
talk about starting and stopping services. So
when we're in Cali, there are a couple different
ways that we can start and stop services. And
when I talk about a service, I'm talking about
something like a web server, or SSH, or maybe a
sequel database. So we cover this video today,
I'm going to show you a few different services
and how to start them and stop them. I'll show you
how to start them permanently on boot. And we'll
talk about which services are important to keep
on boot, which services are important to start
when you feel like that just starting them or when
you need them, etc. So let's start with our first
service, which is going to be Apache two. Now
Apache two is a web server. So let's go ahead and
do a proof of concept. First, let's start with
a command that we learned in an earlier video,
which is if config. I'm going to grab our ipv4
address right here. And I just want to copy this,
I want to go out to a web browser over here. And
we're just going to paste this address. Now you'll
notice that it says it's unable to connect, this
is expected here we're not running a web server.
Now let's go back in here. And let's just say
service, Apache to start. Okay, looks like it went
through, let's go ahead and hit Enter again. And
now you can see that Apache to Debbie and default
page has been loaded. So what has changed? Well,
when we boot our machine, this Apache two service
is not running by default. So if we want to run
a web page, then we actually have to start up
the service for to work as you just saw here. Now
you can see that if we want to add files or place
files here, well, we're going to have to edit
the var www HTML folder. So if we come out here,
and we go into other locations computer, and then
we go into our bar, www, HTML, you'll see that the
index, that HTML page is here. So if we actually
wanted to maybe host a malicious web page and have
it pointed back to us, this is one way we might do
it right here. If we want to serve up some files,
say we have something that we want to upload to
a machine that might be malicious, or, you know,
a file that we want to transfer to somebody else
or download on another computer doesn't have to be
malicious, we could host that file in this folder
here. Now that is fine. This is one way to do it,
right, you can put your files all in one location.
But you know, it's not my favorite way, it was my
favorite way when I first got started. There is a
much easier way now and I will show you how to do
that. So let's go ahead and type ls, you'll see
we have no documents here. So I'm just going to
echo Hello into Hello dot txt, and then have that
Hello dot txt here. Now what we can actually do
is we can spin up a web server. So we can just
say Python dash M for module and say simple HTTP
server, you can auto tab it, and then say 80 for
the Port 80 is already in use. So let's just give
it 80 8080 is in use from the Apache server at the
moment. So instead, let's look at what happens.
So let's just call it out at 8080. And you can
see here that I can go to this Hello dot txt
and actually get the file, I have information in
real time whether or not that file was captured.
And overall, this is just a web server that's so
easy to spin up, I can put it in the directory
that I want it to. So if I wanted to serve my
desktop folder, I would navigate to desktop and
then spin this, this Python module up. I don't
have to put everything into a VAR www folder.
And it just makes life really, really simple.
So just proof of concept. We can do a service,
Apache to stop and we can come back and make sure
that that web server has been stopped by going
here. and refreshing. Now you can see that it's
gone, we can CD into something like downloads,
we say LS, there's nothing in here. So we can tab
up a couple times, and just serve up Port 80. Now,
because you can see it's not in use anymore.
And come back here, refresh, you can see there's
nothing in the directory listing, because there's
nothing in the folder. So this is just an easy way
to spin up a web server, I think it's much easier
than Apache two, I'm showing you both because they
like to give alternatives. But using Python moving
forward is a great, great feature. My challenge to
you is to look up how to spin up a FTP server
with Python. So I won't get redundant here. I
do have future lessons and other courses that
talk about this. But if you want to challenge
yourself to figure out how to spin up an FTP
server, that's my challenge to you, there's
a module out there that you can download quite
easily and spin up your own FTP server. So let's
go ahead and Ctrl C, and we're going to close out
of this. And now let's talk about spinning up a
service permanently. So let's say that we just had
the Apache two running and then we rebooted the
machine. When we reboot our machine. Apache two is
not going to be online. Because we're only doing a
service start, it only holds during this session.
Once we reboot that it session is gone, that
service is gone. So if we want to keep something
online the entire time, what we can do is use
system CTL. So we can say system CTL. Enable or
Disable if you want to disable something. And
for example, we can say SSH now I'm not going to
hit enter here. This is just as an example. Let's
say that we wanted to have an SSH available on our
machine so we can SSH into it. We are opening up
SSH for this feature here. Okay, let's say that
we want to have a server and this is one I do
want you to hit enter in. This is going to be a
database, right? This is a PostgreSQL. So we're
going to say systemctl enable PostgreSQL. And
we have enabled that so now when we reboot this
PostgreSQL will load every single time. Now, why
is this important? Well, this is important because
it's going to allow us to run meta sploit and have
the PostgreSQL database running when we boot so it
doesn't have to take the extra time to load it. If
we come over here, and we just click on the meta
sploit framework. Now PostgreSQL is working, and
it says database already started. So it's already
configured, it's going to skip initialization. And
it's going to go ahead and get right into it. So
it just says a little bit of time that display can
take some time to to run. And I think that if you
continue on, I know if you continue on with being
a pen tester, you're definitely going to be using
medispa quite a bit. So this is just one feature
that if you're going to be using it, it doesn't
hurt to have it enabled on your system boot.
Now if you feel that you want to have a patchy
two on boot, you can go ahead and do the same
thing with the system enable systemctl enable,
but the only one that I recommend putting on is
this system CTL PostgreSQL. Okay, so that is it
for this video. In the next video, we're going
to be talking about installing how to install
things from GitHub and how to install using apt
get. So let's go ahead and move right into that
video. All right, welcome to the Penn ultimate
video, we are going to be focusing on installing
and updating tools. So let's look at our agenda.
So what are we going to learn we're going to learn
how to install updates for Kali. So we're going to
learn how to install updates using a tool called
apt get. And we're also going to learn how to
install tools using apt get specifically we're
going to be installing a tool today called get
we're going to be using Git then to clone from a
website. So sometimes when we have a tool that we
want, it's not always in apt get, it's not in the
repository. So we're going to actually have to use
GitHub and maybe use a tool called Git to download
tools or other items from GitHub. But this is
just going to be one example. But it's a very,
very common example that you may have to do as a
pen tester. So let's dive in and take a look at
how we can use these commands to install tools and
update tools. Okay, so one of the important things
you need to know is how to not only install files
on your computer, but also how to install updates
on your computer. So for Cali, since it's a Debian
base, we're going to use something called apt get
and the first thing I'm going to show you is how
to install updates. So the common way to Do this,
if you don't use the GUI and you want to use the
terminal is apt get update. And then we'll do
and apt get, upgrade. Let's go ahead and just hit
enter on this. Let's explain what it's doing. So
the first command here is saying apt get update.
So what we're doing is we're looking through
packages. Now these packages are predefined the
repositories. And what it does is it says, Okay,
I'm going to check packages here for updates. And
it went through looks like they use archive Linux,
dude, it you, they check these packages here.
And they update the packages. And then once they
update the packages, they run this command. So
basically, the Add command is you're going to do
something as well, right? So first, we're going
to update and then we're going to upgrade. So
based on what's in these packages, it's gonna say,
Okay, well, we know the following packages were
automatically installed and no longer required.
So all these things right here, they're gonna be
removed. And then the following packages have been
kept back, okay, they're fine. They're not going
to uninstall those. And then we have the fine
packages that are going to be upgraded. Okay,
so it's a long list that needs updating. And
then you come in here, and you say, Okay, well,
it needs 252 megabytes of additional disk space
to continue, you can hit enter for Yes. And it'll
automatically start upgrading. So if you want to
update your machine to its newest and best form,
you can go ahead and do that, I'm going to go
ahead and just hit no on this guy. Okay, and now,
it's also important to know how to install files.
So I'm going to show you two different ways. One
way is through apt get similar to what we just
did. And the other way is going to be through
Git itself. So let's go ahead and install git,
we're going to use apt get to install Git. So it
will look something like this, we'll just say apt
get install, get. And we'll hit yes on this. And
another way to do this is to add a dash y at the
end of this. So you'd say apt dash get install,
get dash y. And that'll automatically say yes,
if you just want to accept whatever's coming out
for you, you go ahead and just hit yes on that.
And it may take a minute for these to install.
While this is installing, let's go ahead and talk
about what Git does. So Git works with GitHub. So
when we talk about GitHub, we're talking about a
lot of people update their projects, their code,
their frameworks onto GitHub, especially in the
penetration testing slash hacking community,
it's often that you're gonna find some cool
tools that are out there that are installed
on Kali Linux can't be found through apt get, and
you have to actually download them from GitHub.
So it's very important to know how to use Git.
And it's very, very simple. So we're on a page
like this. This is Vail framework. It's a very
popular tool in penetration testing and malware
analysis as well. So say we wanted to install
this, well, there's a couple things we could
do. The first thing we could do is always read the
directions and see what they recommend. There is
a quick install here. And if you look, they have
a apt install Vale here with the dash y. So that
will work. Or you can use gets install, where you
have to install Git first. Okay, and then we do a
git clone. And we run the configuration setup. So
that's what we're going to do here, we're going
to install Vail just for the fun of it, just so
you can kind of get used to how to use GitHub how
to use Git, and go from there. So let's go ahead
and just Alt Tab back over looks like we have it,
we can check it by typing Git and hitting tab.
Okay, so Git is here. And we're just going to hit
space, we know the command is clone. And while
it provides it for us down here, it says, Hey,
get clone, copy this. The other place you can do
is right here where it says clone or download,
you just copy this bad boy right here. We'll
all tab back over to our terminal and just hit
paste. Okay, and this is going to install in
the directory that you choose. So I just put
it in this root folder here. And actually our home
folder I should say, and it's installed right here
the folder is they all right here. Typically
when I install things, I like to put them in
the OPT folder. So here CD OPT, but since I went
ahead and downloaded here, let's just go ahead for
an example purpose. If you Do you want to install
to object, you're more than welcome, you can move
the folder there as well. So what we're gonna do
is we're going to CD into Vail. And then we'll
hit LS. Now remember, there were instructions. So
let's go ahead and look at what those instructions
were. These instructions said, you're going to
run dot forward slash config. setup that sh,
forced silence, let's go ahead and just copy this
guy. We'll come back in here. And we'll hit paste.
And it's just going to run out of this config
folder, setup that sh. And now it's installing. So
we could have easily installed this with apt dash
kit, which, if you look, look what it's doing,
it's actually rolling through the packages
here. And it's updating the repositories,
right these packages, and then it's going to go
ahead and download what it needs. So it's running
apt get anyway, if you see updating apt, it's
installing the dependencies. So the easier way,
the quick way, which he suggested was to do it
through there, and it's right, they don't always
have the installed packages in apt get. So that's
why I wanted to show you the GitHub version of it.
So you can go ahead and let this install. Let's
just go ahead and recap quickly what we just did.
So we used, we used apt get update, and upgrade to
install updates in our system. We used git clone,
to be able to download packages and clone packages
off of GitHub. And we used apt get to be able to
download Git itself. So that's really it for
this lesson, what I do encourage you to do is go
through the man pages of get and go through the
man pages of apt get, because you're also able
to remove programs, update specific programs, etc.
So this lesson really just wanted to introduce you
to the basics of downloading updating for your
system. I encourage you to learn how to remove
files, as well as a little bit of homework for
yourself. So thank you for joining me, and I'll
catch you over in the next lesson. All right,
welcome to the last lesson video. So in this
video, we are going to be scripting with bash. Now
this may seem a little overwhelming at first, what
we're going to be doing is building out a ping
sweeper script, it's going to be pretty basic.
And what I want you to do is maybe just watch
this video once, and then the second time through,
really try to follow along with it, take notes,
etc, I think of first time watch through you know,
just to get the concepts, understand what
I'm doing. And then the second time really,
really get hands on with it. And I think that will
be probably the best way to learn. But if you have
a different learning style, please do go ahead
and try that as well. The only thing I could say
is don't let this intimidate you. Hopefully by the
time the video is over with you will have a pretty
good understanding on basic scripting and how
scripting can really be beneficial and improve our
timing, improve automation, etc. So let's go ahead
and quickly talk about some of the things we're
gonna be learning in this video. Okay, so some
of the commands and items we're going to learn,
we're going to talk about grep, which is going
to allow us to narrow down some results. We're
also going to talk about cut and T are both of
those are also going to help us narrow down some
results. So basically, we're going to start with a
ping, that we're going to send out and we're going
to want to gather information back that says that
ping was valid. So we want to know any computer
that responded to us. Well, how are we going to do
that? Well, we need to identify what a valid ping
looks like, we're going to use grep to to kind of
narrow down a string or a sentence or something
that identifies with a positive Ping. And then
we're going to cut out everything we don't want
and use tr as well to cut some things out that
we don't want. So we're going to put this into
a script when it's all said and done. And we're
also going to be talking about the usage of for
loops and their importance, not only with using
them in this script, but how we can use simple
one liners to do everyday things for us. So I'll
show you at the end of the video how we're going
to use like n map and use a for loop with n map to
run through and map scripts. So stay tuned through
the video. Again, if you are a hands on learner,
maybe first time through you you try hands on but
my recommendation here is to just sit back, watch
the video understand what's going on. Second time
really follow along with it, take notes and get
the most that you can know this lesson. So let's
go ahead and get started. Alright, so now we're
going to be covering bash scripting. So the first
thing we're gonna need to cover before we get
into writing our scripts is how to narrow down
results. And we say narrowing down results. What
we're saying is for given a block of text, and we
want to extract some information from that block
of text, how are we going to do that? So that's
what we're going to cover in this lesson. Okay, so
let's go ahead and get started. What we're going
to be doing today is narrowing down a ping result.
So if we come into here, and we need to ping an IP
address within our system, so I'm going to be
pinging 192 dot 168, dot one dot 90. And you're
going to see that it returns a 64 bytes from
that address. So it looks like we're getting
a response. I'm going to hit Ctrl C here. So
if you remember from the networking section,
we actually get a response unlimited until we
cancel it, right, like we just Ctrl C here from
Ping. So there's another thing that we can do, if
we only want to send one packet and see if it's
alive or not, we can do a dash c of one. So we're
just going to do that. So that's a count of one,
we're sending one packet over, if we set 10, it
would send 10 packets over if that makes sense.
So now what we're going to do is we're going to
put this into a txt file. So if you remember from
previous video, we just use this little carrot
here. And I'm going to call this IP dot txt. Okay,
and if we cat IP dot txt, you'll see the same
results there. So now what we're going to
want to do is we're going to want to narrow this
down. What do I want to extract from here? Well,
I want to extract this IP address. And it'll
make more sense when we get into the scripting
part. But what we're going to do is we're
going to get out, specifically of this,
this IP address from this line. Now, all we're
interested in actually is a returned IP address
that has a valid response, right? So if I were
to tack, or if I were to enter in here, save 15
dot 90. Okay, there's no response there. So this
is kind of what it looks like. When it doesn't get
a response back, it just kind of lingers. And then
we hit Ctrl C, and it says, zero ping statistics,
right, nothing was was received back. So what
we see when we get a response back, as we see
64 bytes, when there's no response back, we don't
have any bytes. So if we're doing a sweep through
a network, which we're going to be doing later,
we need to be able to narrow down these results.
So if we're sending say 190 2.168 dot 1.1, all the
way through to 55. And we want to see who responds
back and then take that list and narrow it down
to the IP addresses, which exactly what we're
going to be doing, we need to know how to narrow
that down. So we're going to be narrowing down on
specifically is 64 bytes. So let's tab up a couple
times to this cat IP address. And we're going to
do a pipe and the pipe just means we're going to
add an additional command here. So the additional
command we're going to do is called grep. grep
is going to grab any line with what you specify.
So let's specify 64 bytes and see what happens.
See, now if you notice, we had all of these lines
before. And now a grep is doing is grep is taking
only the lines that contain 64 bytes. So again,
a valid response. So we have 64 bytes here. And
we have achieved a response. So what we're going
to do now is we're going to narrow this down some
more. Okay, we've got this line here. But again,
we're still trying to extract this IP address.
So how can we do that? Well, there is a tool
called cut. So if we tap up again, we do another
pipe because they're sending a new command. We're
gonna say cut and cut syntax looks like this. And
I'll explain it once I type it out here. Okay,
so we have cut, and then this hyphen D, that's a
delimiter. So the delimiter is what we're going
to be cutting on. So we're giving a delimiter of
a space, meaning here's a space, here's a space,
here's a space, so we're going to be cutting
on these spaces. And then we give a field,
we say okay, what field we want to retrieve
back from this cut. Okay, we want field four,
if you look 1234 and the fourth field is
our IP address. So it's going to say okay,
I'm going to cut on this space, I'm going to cut
on this space, I'm going to cut on this space,
and then I'm gonna take it right here. Now if we
identified field five, we will be taking this if
we identified field three we'd be taking from so
let's go ahead and just hit enter and see what
that looks like. Okay, so now we are narrowed down
even more. But there's an issue here, if we were
to try to send this IP address, we would have this
little colon here attached on to it, and you can't
ping with that IP address. So we're going to be
doing a sweep or narrowing down this list, then
we're going to actually need to remove this guy
here. So let's take a look at how we do that. So
if we tab up again, and again, we're going to add
a pipe. Now we're going to use a command called
tr. And tr just means translate, what we're going
to be doing is another delimiter. So dash D there,
and we're going to be taking out that colon. So it
should look something like this. If we hit enter,
now you can see that that colon has been removed.
Okay, now let's talk about how we can use this
information to write out a script, we're going to
start with a basic script, and we can add upon it
as we go. So I've gone ahead and written out a
script, but we're going to talk about it very
slowly, so you can actually look at it and copy
it down. So what we're going to do is go ahead
and say g edit, and I call this IP sweep.sh. So
go ahead and do the same or something similar,
and hit enter. So let's take a look at this
script. So at the very top here, we have to
declare what we're doing. So we're going to give
a hash bang. And we do this with any scripting
language. So if was a Python, we'd be entering
Python here, but this is bash. So we're going to
be doing a forward slash bin forward slash bash
that declares that we're running a bash script.
And the.sh also indicates that we're running a
bash script. So I want you to ignore this line
here in this line here. For now, let's talk about
this line. This should look very, very familiar.
So we're doing in this line, we're saying we're
going to ping with a count of one, which we talked
about. And then we're going to do something here,
we've got $1, sign one and $1 sign IP, let's just
ignore that for now. Okay, so we're going to go
ahead and do the rest that should look familiar,
we're going to say we're going to grab 64 bytes,
we're going to cut the delimiter of a space field
before, and then we're going to do a translate,
right and take off that little bit at the end.
Okay, I added an ampersand here at the end. So
an ampersand allows us to do threading. So that's
exactly why it's in there. If we didn't, we'd have
to let the process go one IP at a time. And we'll
talk about that in a second as well. So let's talk
about this four line. So a for loop is what we're
actually running here. And the loop is saying, I
want to do an IP address, we're just declaring a
variable here, you can call it whatever you want.
Or we're saying, hey, for this IP in a sequence of
one through 254, we're going to do something and
that do is a pain. So what this means is for IP,
and if we think about it in sequence one through
254, what it's saying is 1234, all the way up to
254. Okay, so think about it this way, if we say
for one, in this ping sweep, we're gonna do that,
right, so we're gonna say 414243, all the way
through to 34. That's what this loop is doing. So
it's a very, very simple loop. Now, IP is replaced
down here, at the very end. Now, we're also
calling out this dollar sign one. Now this dollar
sign one is user input. So we're going to actually
do something this is called IP sweep, right.
So we're gonna have to call out this IP sweep
something like this.sh. And then we're going to
have to give out some information, it's going
to request information, if we don't provide it,
it won't know how to ping. So we're going to do
is we're going to say the first three octets of
our home network. So if yours is 190 2.16 8.1,
like mine is, then you just enter 192 dot 168
dot one. Now, we could also for simplicity,
just hard code this. So we can say 192 dot 168
dot one.ip address, and it will be fine. We don't
have to build this in the only reason we're not
hard coding it is because you can do multiple pin
sleeves. This can be a ping sweep script for you
in the future if you're on a different network, or
you just want to write something out really quick.
dollar sign one works perfect. But if you want to
leave it hard coded like this, it'll also work. So
let's go ahead and just delete this out. I'm going
to put this into dollar sign one again to have
a proof of concept. And then we are going to run
this. So all we do here at the end is declared
done. If we didn't run this with an ampersand
here, we would have to add a semi colon similar
to this. But because we are having an ampersand
we can actually get rid of that and just put that
back just for some syntax. Clarity here. Okay,
so let's go ahead and save this. And remember from
our lesson, we're going to have to change the mode
of our script because it's not executable by
default. So we're going to do a plus x here.
And then we're going to call our IP sweep that
sh, we can LS and make sure it's green. Here's
ip c.sh. And then we'll do a dot forward slash ip
sweeped a sh, and I'm not going to enter anything
in as want to show proof of concept. So see a ran
through every single number here and threading,
and nameless service not known because we
didn't provide an IP address. So what we can
do here is we need to provide that IP address
168 dot one, hit enter. Okay, and it pulls back
some information. So what we can do with this
information, let's write this out to a file. So
let's just call this IP list dot txt, something
like this. Okay, it's done. Now, let's just cat
out the IP list dot txt. Okay, now we have an IP
list of the IPS in our network that we just swept,
right. And we can use this information later on.
But before we go into that, I do want to go back
and just improve our script a very, very tiny bit.
So let's go ahead and just tab up a couple times.
So we get to our G edit. And let me show you how
we can improve this script, it doesn't have to be
overly complicated, what we can do is, we can say
something like this, we can come in here and give
an if statement. So an IF is conditional,
right? We're gonna say, if this exists,
then do something. And if it doesn't exist, do
something else. So we're gonna say if dollar sign
one is equal to nothing, is going to give blank
space here. And then we're going to say, then we
want to do something. So what are we going to do,
we can echo out something similar to you forgot an
IP address. And then echo out what you need to do.
Like syntax. dot slash ping sweep, or IP sweep is
what we call this IP sweep that sh, and then IP.
Or we can even write it out an example, right?
Like something like that. So that way, our user,
if they're using it, we wrote this for somebody
else, they know what we're talking about. And at
the very end, we just need to write if backwards,
we'll put it ephi. So what this is saying is,
if this is not then echo here, right, we're
going to echo these, and then we need to add one
other thing here, which is an else, let's go ahead
and hit enter, just to space this out a little
bit. So if we have no dollar sign one declared,
right, if we have nothing entered in, we're gonna
say echo, you forgot an IP address and syntax
here. If we do have something in dollar sign one,
okay, we're going to do something else, we're
going to do our ping sweep. And that's it. So this
is very similar and modified from Georgia Weidman
that I've got a long time ago. So full credit goes
to her for this little script, it was very, very
easy to learn. And it's also very easy to teach.
So let's go ahead and just run this one more time,
we're going to say IP sweep the SH. And look what
happens now it says you forgot an IP address. Now
we can declare a number in there anything in the
scripts not perfect, right, we were expecting
three octets. And we could give it a one. And
it's still going to do something like that,
which is incorrect, right? So we need to be able
to, to modify this down more, but that gets really
advanced scripting into declaring that needs to
be three octets. And if you don't provide those,
then what, and that just gets more advanced.
So we really just need to know, hey, what we're
doing here, very basic script for ourselves, and
something to remember. Okay, so let's clear our
screen. Last thing I want to show you. So we've
been able to write a script out. But we can also
do looping in one line. And this is where it
becomes kind of fun. So we have this IP list,
right? We did cat IP list dot Tex. Now let's say
we've got this IP list together, and we want to
do an N map scan on all of these IPS. Now we could
just say and map and type in the syntax you want
and the IP address of it. For every single one of
these start a new tab and let that happen. Or you
could do something in a for loop. So we can write
the same for loop that we did before. We're going
to say for IP, and then we're going to do is we're
going to write $1 sign and we're going to cat the
IP List dot txt. So all it does is is bringing out
this list that we have here and it's saying, okay,
for this IP, this IP, this IP, etc we're gonna run
through all of these. That's what the loop does,
right? Okay, we're gonna do our semi colon, and
then we're going to tell it to do something,
right. So what do we want to do? Okay, let's run
a mF script. So we're going to say do and map.
And we'll ping, or we'll do a port, Port 80 on all
these, and we'll say, still scan that on port 80.
And we'll do t four for a speed. And that should
be yet. So then we can do done like this and let
it run through one at a time. We can also do the
ampersand and let it run multiples like this,
we can hit enter and see what that does. But I
also forgot one thing here, forgot to declare the
IP address. So let's talk about it real quick.
So we've got a very, very simple one liner, and
you're gonna see one liners a lot if you get into
ethical hacking, and just allows us to do things
quickly and scripted. So we got four IP address in
this list. So every IP in this list, we're going
to loop through, when we do that loop, we're going
to do an map, we're gonna do a quick stealth scan
of Port 80 t four, and we're gonna say declare the
IP address. If you're not comfortable with M map,
that's okay, this is purely an example. And
something you will see in your career. I will
make a scripting video at some point for n map.
And we'll cover mF more in detail. So let's go
ahead and just hit enter. Okay, I messed up my
syntax. So what's going on? Okay, so for IP in,
this got deleted for IP and cat IP list. Let's try
this one more time. Okay, so we just did all these
scans seven scans at once. And what we did is, you
see, these are the processes that are starting. So
it started up eight processes, actually not seven.
And it's just running through this list doing the
scans. And we're going to go ahead and just kind
of look at it. So it says, okay, on one dot 74
is at open, it's open, okay. And then on 254
is at open, it's open. And then you see filter
down here, or it's not running, filtered,
filtered, same thing. So we can hit Ctrl C,
or hit enter for done. And that's pretty much it.
So what we just did is we ran a map scans at one
time instead of having to copy and paste these. So
that's just a little bit of what scripting can do.
It does get more advanced. But to be able to know
a one line for loop is a really, really important
if you go into penetration testing. And it's
just important in basic bash scripting as well.
So that's really it for this lesson. And that's
really it for this course. So I hope you really
learned something from this course, if you did
find it valuable. Please do share it with others.
Please subscribe. If you haven't, please do like
the video, word of mouth is the best thing for me,
it helps me grow my channel and helps me give
content back to you as I get more feedback. And
I grow as a channel. So I'm looking to do more
courses in the future. And appreciate you taking
time with me. If you like this course and you want
to chat with me check the descriptions down below,
I've got a discord channel, we've got quite a few
people in there. And I've also got a Twitter if
you want to hit me up there. Lastly, I do have a
Patreon. If you felt like this course is valuable,
and you'd like to support me, any dollar amount
goes a long way for me recording equipment,
recording software, all that's very expensive.
And the time spent on this is also very detailed
long hours. So if you want to support me
or, or anything a like, subscribe, etc,
it goes a long way. I appreciate you taking the
time to watch this course. And until the next one,
thank you so much for joining me. All right, and
now some bonus material. So I'm adding in some
additional resources. These are for those of you
that want to continue on, you've learned Linux now
and you're like, Hey, I really want to be a pen
tester. I think this is for me, I'm gonna provide
you a whole lot of different resources here. So
take notes, these are some of the best resources
I could think of for those wanting to get into
the field. I'll briefly cover each of them and
then leave you added to do your own research
and hopefully, see you in the field someday as a
pen tester. So let's take a look at some of these
resources. Okay, so first resource is a shameless
self promotion. And I only do this because I do
think that I'm a valuable resource. I'm trying
not to be biased here but I've got some good, good
stuff that's completely free if you're interested
in it. So if you come to youtube.com slash c slash
the cyber mentor, you can come to my page here and
you can check out all the videos I have. One video
is a day in the life Have an ethical hacker. So if
you want to know what it's like to be an ethical
hacker, if you're still not sure if this is the
field for you, this might be a video for you to
view talks about the day in and day out stuff that
you might do, what kind of assessment work you
might be asked to do and what it's really like
to be a, an ethical hacker. On top of that,
I've got another video on cyber career paths
about penetration testing and ethical hacking.
So if you're looking to get into the field,
and you want to become a pen tester, or ethical
hacker, and you're not quite sure where to go,
this is probably the better video for you, it kind
of talks about all the knowledge that you'll need
for a junior perspective, and really the knowledge
that you'll need to be successful in the field,
including certifications, etc. So if you're
watching this video as an additional resource,
this will probably be additional resource.
Part two is a good way to call it this is
the one like really detailed on penetration
testing and ethical hacking. On top of that,
over here, I've got playlists. So if you come
into the playlist, I've got a few courses,
most importantly, is our zero to hero course.
So if we come to the cyber mentor.com, and you
go to courses over here, and you go to zero to
hero pentesting You can find more information
on the syllabus. So I put it into lesson plan as
well here, but there are let's see 11 episodes,
we start with Linux kind of like you've already
learned, no keeping some introduction, we do
Python for two weeks, we do information gathering
Oh send recon scanning, enumeration exploitation,
we do internal attacks as well. So we'll build
out an Active Directory lab. And we'll learn
how to do these internal attacks aren't really
taught in a lot of courses. And then we'll end
it with some file transfers, maintaining access,
etc report writing as well and career advice. So
this is like my complete course, it's called zero
to hero to take somebody from from a complete zero
and bring them into hero where they can start
doing some pentesting on their own. So again,
if you're interested in that course, you can come
to my website and check it out with lessons plan,
you can just click in the tab and play the video
or on my YouTube channel, you can click right
on the playlist and play it from there as well.
So leaving the shameless self promotion, let me
talk about some more cheap alternatives. hack the
box is a great, great alternative if you're just
getting started. So for hack the box, what it is,
is it's a series of vulnerable machines. So you
could think of it almost like a game. So if you
want to do some hacking, this is a great place to
just start practicing and learning the ropes. What
we can do is like say we could pick something on
the easy side, you want to look for something
like that's more green right on the left,
because that shows easy, you would pick a box like
this, you would scan against it. And you know,
if you don't know what I'm talking about, that's
fine, but you would scan against it and try to
find vulnerabilities and hack it. So really,
really great website, if you have the VIP,
they're starting to move it, it's in beta right
now. But they have 20 boxes that you can attack
on active side and 20 in the VIP. But the nice
thing about the VIP is they're about to open up
all 97 that had been retired. So they retire one
every week and they bring a new one in. So you
gain access. It's like $13 a month, this is free,
completely free platform if you don't want it but
this is 13 bucks a month for the VIP access. And
you can come in here and do some of these machines
that are super duper easy. And if you click into
them, they'll have write ups for them. And they'll
also have video walkthroughs for a lot of these
machines. So that's a really, really great stuff,
right? If you have no idea what you're doing,
this is a great place to start. Because these
retired boxes are boxes that have already been
done, you can watch how somebody else did them,
you can learn their methodology. And this is
really good for just getting the basics down
and understanding you know, some basic hacking.
Same thing here with the virtual hacking labs,
it's very similar. They've got a labs, they've got
a course and they got different pricing. So you
can try these out if you're interested in them.
So they are, you know, just alternatives to just
practice online. Then you've got bowling hub as
well, you'll have to search through this and try
to find something that's like beginner level or
Google online, which which are realistic boxes,
or what are good boxes on volm. hub of Ohio,
basically you just download the VMware file, and
you play it on VMware and you try to attack the
the machine so you download a machine, you try to
attack it. And these are intentionally vulnerable
machines, all these right here on these top three.
So let's say that that's not really where you want
to start, you think maybe you could use a little
bit more hand holding and you like a certification
to come behind it. I'm going to show you the top
three in my order that I think for pentesting
at least at a beginner to mid tier level,
what the top three are. So either insecurity gets
number one slot in my mind, if you come into here
and you go on to certifications. So they've got
a couple different ones, the ECP PT, or actually,
let's go to courses. So the penetration testing
student and the penetration testing professional,
the student is for the beginner, the professionals
a little bit more advanced leaves off for the
beginner ends. So if we come in the student,
you can see some of the things that you'll
learn. So they've got, you know, it talks about
the preliminary skills that you might need and
teaches you those, it's got some programming,
and then just the basics of penetration testing,
but it gives you an idea what it's like. On top
of that the ISP PTP course they have is like
more in depth more advanced, you start getting
into assembly language and buffer overflows,
you get into network pentesting, some PowerShell,
Linux web app, Wi Fi, some Ruby for medispa light.
So I think this is a really well rounded really up
to date. The downside of this course is that it's
not, it's not really well known on the HR side of
things so and then the pricing can get a little
expensive. On the elite side, right now it's 16
$100. The cheapest is the 1200, I would at least
get the middle tier. But as of right now they're
offering that PTs and the PTP, if you buy the PTP,
they give you the PTS for free, but that won't
be going on much longer. But you can always
hold out for deals like this as well. Another
resource and a very, very well known resource,
probably the best certification in terms of being
known is the O SCP. So it starts out at 800 bucks,
as you can see here, you're probably going to
spend more money than that, because that's just
30 days. So the nice thing about this is it comes
with labs, there's a certain amount of machines in
there that you can try to hack against, sort of
like a hack the box, but it's an environment. So
you can you notice, attack whatever you feel like
and try to navigate your way through the network.
And then when you are done, and you want to test
for the certification, you have to actually hack
in an environment of the set number of machines
you have to hack against. And you have to be
successful in hacking those machines to get your
certification. So it's considered one of the more
difficult certifications out there to achieve.
And you'll see it come up a lot of times in HR
or job applications that they want this oscp. So
this is something to look into and consider as
well. The cost isn't as bad as the elearn. But
the con here is that office of security courses
haven't been updated in five or so years. So you
really need to, you know, it's kind of the best
of both worlds if you were able to do both.
But this one will get you into more doors,
this one will get you a little bit more current.
But there are plenty of resources out there,
all these tabs are showing you that you don't
have to spend a ton of money to get this stuff.
These are more things that if you want that
certification, you want that that coursework,
that knowledge, these are great resources, all
three of these. So last is the G Pen. Now the G
Pen is just an exam. By itself, it's 17 $100. It
is by sans right. So this is showing g i see you
actually have to take the corresponding sans
course that goes with it. And that course is
upwards of $6,000. So unless you can get a
employer to pay for this sans certification,
probably not the best. But the thing that I
like about sans is that it stays up to date,
they are constantly updating their courses, and
that they look good on a resume. It's one of those
really high tier high level certifications. And
the exam from what I hear is actually pretty good.
It's not a practical exam, but it's a fairly
good exam. And the nice thing I didn't mention
elearn security is also a practical so this oscp
is practical, the elearn security exams practical,
you have to hack your way through to to pass and
write a report as well. This one is a multiple
choice exam, I do believe. So these are three
certifications that you can look into if you
wanting to go down that route. I would start with
the PTS if you can, it's dirt cheap. You know,
if I have to make a recommendation just to make
sure that you're you're really interested in this,
if you know for sure. And you want to do that
pts PTP combo, this might be a good choice here.
But other than that, I mean, the free resources
like I've got my channel, there's ton of videos,
the zero to hero course is like at least 20 to 30
hours of material. hack the box you'll spend a lot
of time on there's plenty of write ups if you just
Google like, honestly, if we go into here and we
say like apocalypse here. If you say that and you
Google that with right up, you're going to find
the right up for this or you'll find a video for
this or some kind of walkthrough, right. So you
just want to look through these and try to try it
on your own and then go back And then watch the
write up and see how you could have improved if
you'd got through it. Or where you can improve an
enumeration or whatever it is you need to, to get
better to actually succeed the next time you try
attacking these machines. So that is it. You have
reached the end of this course and the end of the
bonus material. If you need anything, I provided
my contact info again in the beginning. You know,
I'm at the cyber mentor on Twitter, you can reach
me on YouTube as well. And I really do. Thank you
for joining me I look forward to seeing many
of you take the next step from this Linux,
if you made it this far, you've already gotten
through the beginner Linux. That's awesome. I hope
you take this next step and that you are intrigued
by penetration testing because we need more people
in the field. So I look forward to seeing you guys
and girls come through and hopefully I'll work
with some of you someday. So until next time, my
name is Heath Adams and I thank you for joining me